[Music] I'll leave this hat with you
My dear hat car It
's okay, come closer
[Music]
Ahhh
[Applause]
Oh oh oh
Look what
I am
But I don't know about
this, but this is skin that swears its life, so
I'm not joking.
Hey, I don't think there's a new era
they're
talking
about.  [music] hmm
can
I
wished for a little
[music]
aname
[applause] It was
hard for me to eat with
you Thank you very much for taking care of me until now
Kita
I was really happy
[music]
you guys
[MUSIC] If
you've been waiting there for 50 years,
why don't you go on your way for 12 years?
Promise is far
away I want to resume from the front
Ushiku
,
you
love this room
Hook
[music]
Thank you Shinsekai Day Blow you away
Fish-Man Island is too much for me
to make an alliance with your house
[music]
How do you see
me?  If you team up, you might be able to do it.
[Music]
Four schools ranked first
.
[Music]
Huh, we're Waywood Bus hesitant
Ninja Pirate Mikkun
Samurai Alliance Bar
You made a one-sided promise
and said something selfish, but
uhm, it's
always like that
, pushing selfishness  generally
Anyway, but
yeah, you came Ruby did you
know?